In the video on solubility, I
draw little pictures of sodium
and chloride ions when sodium
chloride dissolves or
disassociates into water.
This is sodium and
this is chloride.
And my simple brain, when I
looked at it, I said, OK, how
should I draw these things?
I said, well, they're in the
same period, and sodium is a
Group 1 element.
It's an alkali metal, while
chlorine is a halogen, so
chlorine's going to have a
smaller atomic radius.
And the logic there, just to
review from the atomic table
trends, is that both of their
valence electrons are in the
third shell.
Sodium only has 11 protons
pulling in the center.
It has 11 in the center, and it
has only one electron out
there in its valence shell.
So the attraction isn't as
strong as the case of
chlorine, which has 17 protons
in the center.
Although it has more valence
electrons-- it has 7 of them--
these protons are going
to have a stronger
attraction on them.
So if you just look at the trend
in the periodic table,
you'd expect the sodium neutral
atom to be bigger than
the chlorine neutral atom.
Because this guy has more
protons pulling everything in.
And that's how I drew the
ions in that video.
I said, oh, when I disassociate
in water, I'll
have a big sodium ion and
a smaller chlorine
ion, which is incorrect.
Because think about-- and this
was pointed out to me by one
of the viewers, and they're
correct, and I should have
realized it.
What happens when you
ionize these things?
This guy will lose an
electron, right?
He gives the electron
to this guy.
So his electron configuration
is actually going to look a
lot more like neon.
He now will have no electrons
in that third shell, in the
third energy state.
So now he's going to have an
atomic radius that's actually
much more similar to
neon here, right?
Because he's going to have
filled up the second shelf.
So actually, the sodium ion,
this is completely incorrect.
The sodium ion is going to have
an atomic radius not that
different than neon.
Actually, it will be even a
little smaller than neon
because it has the same electron
configuration, but it
has one more proton.
So the sodium ion is actually
going to be smaller.
Because it gets rid of the
electron in that third shell,
and the chlorine cation, gained
an electron, so it has
completely completed
its third shell.
So here you have where
the chlorine ion
is going to be bigger.
So in that solubility video, I
should've actually switched
the places between the
sodium and the
chlorine, at least in size-wise.
And, of course, I showed how
they disassociate in water,
and this would be attracted to
the oxygen end of the water,
and you have the hydrogen
end and all that.
But you can watch the solubility
video for that.
It doesn't change the real
takeaway from the video.
But I think this is a really
interesting point that it
brings up, that when you ionize
these neutral atoms, it
can significantly change,
especially significantly
change their relative
atomic sizes.
Anyway, hopefully, you found
that interesting.